you had some kind of incident related to
this subject that happened to you on an
airplane recently in the SAP thing you
wanted to sort of get off your chest
I was on Delta Delta Delta Airlines and
I found a piece of poop in my blanket
wait a minute wait a minute mm-hmm no
you did I sure did and it went all the
way up the chain of command and they
were like you found it like it was like
they were looking at wait a minute you
have to tell us take me through this
like I'm a policeman and you're telling
me what happened okay I was on a flight
from Louisiana to Atlanta had been
heading back to LA and I was on the
Descent and I was very chilly so I said
better cover up and I pulled out the
blanket out of this sealed plastic bag
open it a little Brown crumble falls on
me I was like oh my oh my what half that
big but I forged ahead cuz I'm chilly so
I like open it more and I see this like
brown thing in it so I drop it so I was
like is it a animal what is it so then I
open it with my foot this man staring at
me I'm in first class thank you and the
smell hits me and I was like oh my god
oh my god I think that's a piece of poop
and then we landed and I went up to the
flight attendant I was like do you hand
sanitizer I think there's a piece of
poop in my blanket he was like girl no
and I say yes girl yes go look so he
goes he loves me he goes oh my god I
gotta get my phone
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's snapping pictures passengers are
like oh my word Wow no but I know and
then I had to like make my connecting
flight so I tweeted adults and they're
like we'll give you $250 dollars look
you give people more to get off an
oversold flight there was poop in my
blanket give me an airplane sink it was
a disgruntled employee and I was like
really treat them better yeah
[Applause]
nicer oh my gosh it was the wildest
thing and then I found a piece of poop
in my phone like a week later do you
think it was near the I thought someone
was like I gotta get her again you think
the phone was down you're like it was on
my lap oh my god I was following you I
asked for more cuz they gave me a fifty
thousand miles my ticket refunded $600
dollars and then they're like if we give
you more you can't talk about it was
like people need to know to not use a
blanket I think this story on television
with work was worth 600 Delta dollar my
god
[Applause]
you